und in berlin begrüße ich reiner
holznagel präsident des bundes der
steuerzahler holznagel
sie haben ja die klagen gestern
unterstützt und verloren und fühlen sich
dennoch als gewinner ist ja auch nicht
so häufig wie passt das zusammen
naja in der sache haben wir ja gar nicht
verloren die kläger sind nicht
weitergekommen
zumindest haben sie nicht das bekommen
was sie wollten aber das was wir wollten
ist klar und deutlich formuliert worden
nämlich dass eine doppelbesteuerung der
renten durchaus vorliegen kann und wenn
nichts getan wird auch definitiv
vorliegen wird und der
bundesfinanzminister und sein
staatssekretär wir haben ja sofort
reagiert und haben auch schon gesagt
dass sie da etwas tun wollen
insofern war es ein voller erfolg nicht
nur für uns sondern für alle
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
sie haben sie eben angesprochen das
bundesfinanzministerium hat reagiert
aber doch eigentlich die ganze
angelegenheit erst mal ein bisschen auf
die lange bank geschoben man hat gesagt
in dieser legislaturperiode
bloß nicht wenn dann in der nächsten
jahren da muss sich doch erstmal eine
neue bundesregierung formieren da muss
man sich ja erstmal einigen überhaupt
wie man mit einer steuer und
rentenreform umgehen will das wird doch
alles noch jahre möglicherweise dauern
also man muss zur wahrheit eben auch
sagen dass das bmf also das
bundesfinanzministerium auch vorher sehr
stark gebloggt hat und das immer wieder
verneint hat das eine doppelbesteuerung
vorliegt unsere musterkläger sind ja
sehr frühzeitig schon in die rente
gegangen und deswegen ist der anteil
ihrer rente nicht so sehr hoch besteuert
worden
aber es wird ja eben klar dass all
diejenigen die jetzt kürzlich in rente
gegangen sind oder künftig in rente
gehen werden einen höheren anteil der
besteuerung haben und hier hat der bfh
ja auch die doppelbesteuerung
festgestellt ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass sie im vorfeld viel mehr gemacht
worden ist wir dürfen das thema
rentenbesteuerung auch grundsätzlich
nicht aus den augen verlieren viele
menschen fühlen sich hier überfordert
deswegen ist es nicht nur an der sache
jetzt eine neue rentenformel zu finden
sondern insgesamt das system auch zu
vereinfachen
sie haben es eben angesprochen viele
menschen fühlen sich überfordert was
muss ich denn jetzt machen wenn ich
jetzt in den nächsten jahren in rente
gehe und der meinung bin dass auch meine
rente doppelt besteuert wird
also zunächst sollte man wirklich jetzt
sehr aufmerksam die politik beobachten
das tun wir auch und olaf scholz hat ja
schon gesagt wer weiß was er nach der
wahl auch begleiten wird leiden abend
aber das erst mal eine andere frage aber
nach der wahl muss die bundesregierung
sehr sehr schnell reagiert insofern ist
das zeitfenster jetzt auch sehr klein
und dann wird man sehen wie sich die
rentenpolitik an dieser stelle verändert
in jedem fall muss man seinen
steuerbescheid sehr sehr sorgfältig
studieren und gegebenenfalls wenn man
das gefühl hat dass eine
doppelbesteuerung vorliegt einspruch
einlegen das hilft in jedem fall immer
ich erwarte von der bundesregierung von
der administration dass sie jetzt
schnell reagiert dass sie auch den
menschen eine handreichung bietet wie
jetzt mit diesem problem umzugehen ist
denn wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
menschen sind an dieser stelle schlicht
und ergreifend sehr gefordert und gerade
im alter noch mal eine steuererklärung
abzugeben ist für viele eine große
herausforderung und das ist glaube ich
für die politik auch ein warnsignal
jetzt eine ganz spannende frage ist doch
wer wird jetzt von dieser neuen
rechtsprechung eigentlich profitieren
olaf scholz sagt es sind die kleinen
leute der normale rentenzahler in
anderen berichten hört man dass es eher
die gut verdienen diejenigen die
selbstständigen die privat eingezahlt
haben dass die von dieser neuen
rechtsprechung profitieren werden wer
wird dann am ende mehr rausholen
diese frage kann ich in konkret nicht
beantworten weil es wirklich immer und
individuelle verhältnisse geht wie lange
ist eingezahlt wurden in welche kasse
ist eingezahlt worden wie es die
erwerbsbiografie gewesen deswegen kann
man jetzt nicht pauschal sagen dass alle
rentner mit soundso viel euro davon
profitieren
fakt ist dass ein grundsatzurteil
gefällt worden ist was sehr sehr hilft
nämlich dass eine doppelbesteuerung
nicht zulässig ist und damit hat der
fiskus keine verluste sondern die
rentnerin und rentnerin rentner einfach
mehr geld und das ist glaube ich das
thema und wir führen ja seit jahren eine
debatte dass die alterssicherung immer
mehr auch in den fokus der politischen
aktionen gerät und hier hat die politik
jetzt eine vorlage bekommen
auf der steuerlichen seite auch bessere
rahmenbedingungen eine faire und
gleichmäßige besteuerung für alle
drinnen und rentner auch herzustellen
das möchte ich am schluss mal auf ein
anderes thema eingehen was aber am ende
vielleicht das gleiche thema ist das die
neue rechtsprechung des bfh wird ja ein
milliardenloch in den bundeshaushalt
reißen und der bundeshaushalt ist ja
sowieso schon alles andere als
ausgeglichen über 200 milliarden
schulden dieses jahr werden ja erwartet
wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus wird
sich der staat das nicht wieder an
anderer stelle bei den steuerzahlern
holen müssen was erwarten sie da in den
nächsten monaten in den nächsten jahren
naja das milliardenloch ich kann das
erst mal gar nicht so sehen das
milliardenloch entsteht dadurch dass
noch mehr ausgaben geplant werden
wir dürfen da nicht drumherum kommen
dass auch im nächsten jahr wieder auch
eine sparpolitik geschlossen werden muss
wir dürfen wir müssen alle ausgaben mal
auf den prüfstand stellen das glaube ich
gehört mit zur wahrheit aber am ende
müssen wir alles dafür tun das
wirtschaftswachstum entsteht dass arbeit
und beschäftigung entstehen und das
werden wir nicht generieren indem wir
steuererhöhungen organisieren und da
glaube ich muss die politik noch mal in
sich gehen einige parteien vor daniel
massive steuererhöhungen am ende und das
sehen wir aus frankreich gerade wenn ihr
von wenn eine vermögensbesteuerung
eingeführt wird bleibt den fiskus und
dem strich weniger steuern weil
abwanderungs passiert weil kein
wirtschaftswachstum passiert also mit
steuererhöhungen kommen wir aus dieser
krise definitiv nicht und deswegen
sollten wir alles dafür tun dass die
einnahmen stabil bleiben aber die
ausgaben endlich sinken
das fordert rainer holznagel präsident
vom bund der steuerzahler herzlichen
dank nach berlin für dieses gespräch
dann gehen